Now, it's your turn to make a form and
Flask.
Create a template called,
editMenuItem.html that allows me to
edit the name, of a specific menu item.
A major difference between this form,
and
the new menu form is that now
you should find the menu item,
you want to edit, and pass that in
with the render template function.
Use the placeholder tag in HTML,
so that the user sees the information
that they're about to modify.
Also, add a link called, Cancel that
will take me back to the main menu page,
if I decide I don't want to
modify a menu item.
In the instructor notes, you'll find
a project.py file that already has
the editMenuItem function filled out, so
you just need to create the form
that will communicate with it.